okay so demisexual is described as a
person who only feels sexual attraction
when there's an emotional bond aka a
woman
and then she said quote hip or cool to
not be hetero in my liberal bubble
the country does not have a future with
this kind of stuff it just does not it's
so wonderful
to be a member of the intersectional
coalition that everybody wanted and so
we're now just going to make up things
so that you too can be a member of the
intersectional coalition which brings me
to my favorite story of the day
michaela kennedy cuomo 23 is governor
andrew cuomo's daughter
she came out in an instagram post last
month as queer now we used to believe
that
that queer you know now having been
hijacked from a term of derogation
as a derogatory is now used by members
of the gay community as sort of a
championing term
right it used to mean gay bisexual
lesbian right it used to mean something
along those now
michaela kennedy cuomo came out as
demisexual
according to webmd demisexual people
only feel sexually attracted to someone
when they have an emotional bond
she says when i was in elementary school
i feared that i was a lesbian when i was
in middle school i came out to my family
and close friends as bisexual when i was
in high school i discovered pansexuality
and thought that's the flag for me
i've recently mourned learned more about
demisexuality and have believed
that that identity resonates with me the
most
and then she said she has always dreamed
of a world in which nobody will have to
come out because everybody's sexuality
will be assumed fluid
but in a world that force-feeds
cisgender heterosexuality coming out of
the closet is a lifelong process of
unpacking
internalized social constructions and
stigmas
and she is she is demisexual she added
the one she first came out as queer she
feared she'd be
perceived as attention seeking since
it's quote hip or cool to not be hetero
in my liberal bubble
and there in lies each okay so what the
hell's the demisexual you ask yourself
so again webmd now list demisexual as
quote
only feel sexually attracted to someone
when they have an emotional bond
okay now demisexual started off as a fan
fiction role play forum in 2004
on a made-up identity in a middle
schooler's character
okay and and now it's on webmd okay so
demisexual
is described as a person who only feels
sexual attraction when there's an
emotional bond
aka a woman a woman
what studies demonstrate repeated social
science and hard science studies
suggest that women tend to have higher
sexual satisfaction by leaps and bounds
when they have an emotional connection
to the person with whom they are having
sex
but now this is considered some sort of
minority sexuality demisexuality
everybody is so interested in jumping on
the intersectional bandwagon because
again
if you're part of the coalition then
you're not part of the evil
law of the united states the evil blob
that is the united states
the left is banking on this they've
weaponized our institutions in favor of
this sort of nonsense
and it has a pretty predictable effect
the demonization of people across the
other side of the aisle and the attempt
to subjugate the institutions of the
country
and destroy them as somehow not
benefiting you
the country does not have a future with
this kind of stuff it just does not and
the more young people who feel that it
is popular to join the quote unquote
coalition of the
oppressed because you're either the
oppressor or the oppressed in the binary
ibrahim x kennedy nonsense construct
the more people who buy into that
construct and then decide they're going
to be a member of the oppressed group
because there's only victims and
victimizers in american society
the more the united states is going to
be in serious serious trouble and we can
see that each and every day
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe